you
I would take anyone into the laboratory
that was accepted by the department
because it's a pretty good department
and the quality standards were pretty
high and I don't think that the criteria
we have for you know judging students
prior to them getting into the
laboratory and doing science are very
good so you know it's a matter of giving
people a chance to see what they can do
and you know in my experience about half
of them are cut out to be scientists and
you know about half of them aren't is
there anything in particular that
distinguishes early on those that are
cut out for it well it's I think it's a
couple of things it's it's a strong
sense of determination and commitment
and it's also an ability to think for
themselves and those are and and then
there's a for laboratory science a
factor of you know what people call good
hands where you can make things work or
you can't and nobody really quite knows
what that is
but those three things are are pretty
critical and the the sense of
self-confidence that's needed to make
your own judgments and you know even to
argue with your mentor about you know
whether something's important or
meaningful or you know an experiment
worth doing those are very good signs
when a student's willing to argue with
you and you know whereas primarily in in
in undergraduates we just judge
intellectual abilities by whether they
pass test or not and and I didn't even
mention that I'm sure that's that's an
element as well but these other three
things are really important in
laboratory science